Bangladesh is the only country with an
Islamic majority whose president is a
woman her name is Sheikh Hasina and this
is not a little example we're talking
about the third biggest Muslim country
with more than a hundred and sixty
million inhabitants nonetheless there is
one Bangladeshi even more famous than
Sheikh Hasina
this is Muhammad Yunus seize the Nobel
Peace Prize winner as well as the
inventor of microcredits he's also from
Bangladesh
this is surprising given that in this
country only one out of every three
citizens has a bank account so
Bangladesh is one of the fastest growing
economies of the last few years they
have reduced poverty faster than anyone
else and they are also the world's
second largest textile manufacturer only
surpassed by China but despite all of
that most of the Bangladeshi people
still keep their money at home so now
you might be wondering well why is this
what exactly is going on in Bangladesh
that causes people not to trust the
banks well the answer to this well its
religion according to Islam lending
money with interest is a sin and 90% of
the Bangladeshi people are Muslim but
wait just a minute here because things
they are changing in the last few
decades Muslim countries have created a
system that allows saving and lending
money which also meets their Islamic
principles yes dear viewer we are
talking of course about Islamic banking
a phenomenon that is becoming more and
more important in Bangladesh and you
might think that this is great news for
the governments of Sheikh Hasina rice
well in fact the opposite is actually
true Islam be back Bangladesh is
most-watched bankers so now the question
becomes why does the government of
Bangladesh distrust Islamic banking and
more importantly what role might Islamic
banking have in the future of Bangladesh
well today we're going to answer those
questions but before we do let's answer
the most important question of all
what's Islamic banking all about ok so
imagine we have a thousand American
dollars and they're just sitting in a
savings account a Western Bank can give
you an interest rate of say 3 percent
now I'm sure many of you have wondered
well how is it possible that a bank just
gives us money for money that is simply
sitting in it but where's the profit
here well the truth is that that $1,000
it's not just staying in the bank's safe
instead they use that money to lend to
companies and individuals those loans
they simply have a higher interest rate
so the bank makes money and gives us a
little share of that profit this is the
basic mechanism of the entire system of
Western banking
now obviously this carries some degree
of risk because the bank can lose the
money but depending on the country we
live in the bank is forced by law to
keep a small percentage of that $1000
that percentage it cannot be lent and
it's calls the cash ratio now according
to Sharia law
this system is sinful because lending
money with interest is seen as unfair of
course there is no problem with keeping
your clients money but you simply can't
lend it to anyone in economic jargon
this means that Sharia law demands a 100
percent cash ratio so this in summary is
the way that Islamic banks work and now
you'll be wondering well where exactly
is the business here well mainly Islamic
banks will make money by two means first
the banks charge their clients
commissions for keeping the money so
instead of giving you an interest rate
as la mukbang can only give you a little
symbolic presence this present it's
called the Habad another business
practice that is allowed by Sharia law
is adding over costs for example let's
say we buy a house with an Islamic bank
in this case the bank will buy the house
for us and then sell it to us at a
higher price this price is called the
Moshe rocker and we can pay for it in
installments if for whatever reason we
can't complete the payments the tank
will sell the house on the market if
they do get some profit from this
selling we the clients can take a share
of the profits but wait just a minute
here because this is not the end of the
story
the current bans banks from investing in
what they considered dirty businesses
such as tobacco weapons or pornography
it's even a special index the Dow Jones
Islamic markets has 1,400 companies from
the New York Stock Market where Islamic
banks can invest as you can imagine
these banks are becoming really
successful in several Muslim countries
but well in Bangladesh
they are absolutely kicking ass Islamic
banking is growing rapidly in Bangladesh
with a market share of about 20 percent
today there are already eight banks of
this time in Bangladesh even Western
banks like City are starting to offer
Islamic banking services for those who
demand them in a country where bribes
are a thing everywhere Islamic banks are
famous for their transparency and good
practices Islamic banks for instance a
famous of having nothing to do with the
Bangladeshi government
so if you want to get a loan from an
Islamic bank you have to demonstrate
that you are a reliable client willing
to pay back your debts but hold on a
minute here because well things they are
not as good as they might seem for these
banks
good Bank bad Bank Islamic banking
arrived in Bangladesh in 1983 when some
Saudi and Kuwaiti hedge funds decided to
create the islami Bank this Bank played
a crucial role in turning an
agricultural country into the textile
powerhouse that it is today today
clothes make up 80 percent of
Bangladeshi exports and islami Bank is
the biggest bank in the country
nonetheless the growth of Islamic
banking in the country is not clear
anymore our central bank is not giving
new Islamic banking licenses even those
Western banks that want to give Islamic
banking services must wait they claim
they need to create brand new
regulations on the matter of Islamic
banking meanwhile the governments of
Sheikh Hasina has sent inspectors to the
islami Bank officers and they are
surveying all of their movements
the government initiates a coup at
Bangladesh's biggest bank board members
receive a visit from military
intelligence
so now you might wonder what is wrong
with the Islamic banks and the
government's well Sheikh Hasina claims
that they are financing terrorism as we
explained in another video Islamic
terrorism is becoming a real threat to
the country and many people think some
of these banks might be financing
terrorist groups
however there are several reasons the
makers believe that at the end of the
day this is nothing but a power struggle
Sheikh Hasina loves to take things under
her control in the fact that the biggest
bank in the country sympathizes with the
proposals of the opposition party
certainly does not help this is why on
January 2017 Haseena interviewed the
Islamic bank and changed the board of
managers by her own supporters
since then loans of skyrocketed the
Bangladesh central bank itself has
warned that some of these loans are too
risky meanwhile both Saudi and Kuwaiti
hedge funds that created the Bank 35
years ago are now taking back their
money they simply don't think it is safe
anymore but wages diminutive because
this is not the first time that shakers
seniors tried to control the financial
industry in their country
you know the guy he mentioned in the
beginning Muhammad Yunus well he is in
Hasina's crosshairs
- in the year 2006 after some terrorist
attacks the Bangladeshi army organized a
coup d'etat and created a technocratic
government back then Muhammad Yunus was
a favorite candidate to lead that
government in the end though that didn't
happen but Hasina learned a vital lesson
beware of the bankers sometimes they
like to get involved in politics this is
why has seen as first priority after
taking position in 2008 was to take care
of Yunus first of all she forced him to
resign as the chairman of his own bank
for Grameen Bank
of course some of our claims were true
and make no mistake muhammad yunus is
not a perfect guy but we're gonna talk
about that in another video but as if
making him resigned was not enough
Haseena also started a campaign to
diminish his image in Bangladeshi
society Nobel laureate unis got Hillary
Clinton to stop WV funding for Padma
bridge says Hasina in other words Sheikh
Hasina knows how to beat our political
enemies first it was Yunus now it's the
Islamic banks
so the question is now do you think
there is an actual connection between
Islamic banks and terrorism or is this
just an excuse made are Bechet Cocina in
order to keep the finance industry under
control and should Bangladesh allow
Islamic banks to operate in the country
without restrictions well please leave
your comments in the comment section
below also visit our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that are not
mine also check out my other channel
biographic s' we do long-form
biographies of people from history as
well as the present day and if you liked
this video please do hit like and do
subscribe because we put out brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
and as always thank you for watching and
if you want to learn more about politics
and here even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider mediacom
slash podcast CFA